[Musique]
ma fille je travail de 4 heures du matin
jusqu'à 8h 9h ce soir je vois pas mes
enfants à cause de ça je m'appelle
sylvain pelletier jeu se trouve
chauffeur de taxi maintenant depuis un
an auparavant deux ans pour hubert
mettant les voitures sont beaucoup plus
propres et les chauffeurs de taxi sont
de plus en plus souriant et il travaille
pour essayer d'offrir le meilleur
service
l'arrivée d'hubert causé un peu comme de
se mettre à jour pourrait essayer de
donner un meilleur service
mais là présentement avec le projet 3,17
on est en train de détruire le taxi
complètement on veut pas faire en sorte
que le taxi s'améliore ce qu'ils veulent
il y aura plus de réglementation le
maintenant le taxi va être déréglementé
salle annonce la mort du taxi
complètement
[Musique]
l'industrie du taxi a changé il y a
beaucoup plu compétition depuis la venue
des applications mobiles le marché
saturé
il n'y a plus assez de travail pour nous
[Musique]
il faut qu'au bout de grodno sache que
ça reste un os pour l'instant apple en
couple bat moi comme j'ai eu peur ils
sont pas ces pays il vient de recoller
dans nos aéroports c'est pas possible
c'est pas juste car ils ont fait le même
métier mais
sauf c'est à des genres et amis quoi moi
j'ai mis des 138 euros pour faire 7
métiers et plus la voiture 30000 ça fait
deux cent soixante mille euros
[Musique]
c'est la meilleure chose qui me soit
arrivée je fais du taxi depuis très
longtemps et les gens me disaient que
j'étais stupide de ne pas m'acheter un
terme mais quelque chose cloche est
mathématiquement
pourquoi payer un million de dollars
pour un permis alors que vous pourriez
le perdre pour n'importe quelle raison
c'est dû à la fin une journée maintenant
sur le tas ici de 12 heures parce que
quand ça roule peau mais vous avez
tendance à vous endormez il faut que ça
bouge
quand vous faites de l'argent et vous
générer des revenus vous êtes tendance à
être motivée mais cette motivation le
dans le taxi vous l'avez pas mais sur
hubert vous l'avez mais vous faites pas
d'argent c'est ça la différence parce
que hubbard ça vole tout le temps il ya
toujours de la clientèle qu'est ce qui
est arrivé avec l'état c'est cuba pour
devenir légal le gouvernement ont exigé
d'avoir certaines sommes sur le chaque
course qui est collecté pour l'industrie
du taxi et cet argent alors est enlevée
directement dans les poches chauffeur du
beurre alors c'est le chauffeur qui a
été pénalisé sur le projet pilote du bar
et non hub a été pénalisé hubert ont
toujours mis le 25 pour ça dans leur
poche
avant c'était cool taxi soit concert
blues 7 8 ans ne va on voit que l'élu
berckois partout mais bon je suis pas
contre les chauffeurs moi et je
contrôlais la loi que nous on paye la
licence est pourquoi elle ne donne pas
des licences gratuits pour travailler
des débats où nous rembourse qu'on a
payé quoi après pas de problème tout le
monde peut travailler mais lui lui
berlin c'est gratuit jamais une voiture
travail comme nos difficultés pour
trouver des clients
la situation empire de jour en jour
la nuit dernière je n'ai pas eu de
clients pendant deux ans
quand vous ne trouvez pas de clients
pendant deux heures vous devez quand
même dépensé en moyenne 19 $ l'heure
pour la location et les sens
vous finissez par brûler du carburant y
brûler votre santé aussi ça vous met en
colère et vous devenez furieux et
anxieux là vous allez faire des courses
vous allez déposer le client six minutes
après vous allez avoir un appel ça
libère pour faire une autre course
alors vous avez toujours la motivation
de travailler alors que dans le taxi
d'aller travailler 12 heures mais vous
allez attendre peut-être une heure soit
un poste avant d'avoir un appel donc
c'est vraiment plus dur de finir une
journée de 12 ans on cherche on cherche
on cherche on fait beaucoup de
kilomètres pour trouver on trouve pas
donc c'est ma toute façon la région ema
je peux pas je peux plus continuer comme
ça il ya une passe en deux ans huit de
nos collègues chauffeurs se sont
suicidés des cours les chauffeurs qui
ont pris une hypothèque pour acheter
leur permis ne pouvait plus faire leurs
paiements comme leurs revenus ont
diminué de moitié alors que le prix du
permis a augmenté lui jusqu'à plus d'un
million de dollars je vais vendre une
reste rien quoi j'ai acheté la licence
j'avais un apport de 50000 euros et
maintenant je vendais ne reste pas sans
contenu lorsque j'ai mis à cinq ans
oui donc si c'était pas hubert et je
vends ma licence maintenant au moins je
gagne
cent cinquante mille euros dans la poche
je peux plus travailler comme ça c'est
trop difficile quoi c'est pas une vie
quoi on lui une seule une seule fois
donc mais pas nul comme ça dans stress